less than three months after New Jersey
housewife Teresa Giudice is released
from prison her husband Joe is about to
begin his three-plus your sentence for
multiple offenses including tax evasion
and our senior news editor Jennifer
perros has the only interview the couple
is doing before their family is
fractured again because a mother finally
free a father behind bars tonight's top
story shall we send Joe the last days of
freedom have you said anything to Joe
yet to kind of prepare him for what it
may be like the biggest thing I guess
don't trust anyone
I think that's the easy part going to
jail I think it's what they put you
through before you go they try to
mentally and physically break it down
you know them and so uh that's I think
the hardest part of everything you know
I think going to jail is easy court that
will happen in just 21 days reality
stars Joe and Teresa Giudice were
convicted on federal fraud charges
Teresa who made headlines for this table
flip served eleven and a half months in
prison she was released 70 days ago and
now well it's Joe's turn the father of
four faces 41 months behind bars listen
today the kids got computers they go on
computers they know everything I mean my
daughter Milania tells me you're going
away for a lot more Munster mommy
what do you think you'll miss the most
of not having your husband at home him
being so handy around the house I mean
that's it
uh-huh no I mean that part I mean I'm
gonna miss of course sleeping with him
at night and cuddling with him me keeps
me warm I'm gonna miss the passion and
well I can't say don't worry the New
Jersey housewife says at least once a
week she will make the hour and a half
trip to see Joe at the Federal
Correctional Institute in Fort Dix New
Jersey now I hate to ask this the
conjugal visits are not allowed in the
state of New Jersey right at federal
prison Deanna
settlement that lawyer that's mother
stupid thing doesn't make any sense
Teresa says she fell in love with yoga
during her time in prison I'm definitely
and a lot calmer than I was and we've
learned she's trying to get Joe into the
practice before his sentence what's the
best part of having her home the best
part is uh she's doing her mommy duties
again that's off my shoulders now
last night I want to go say goodnight to
Milania and um she was saying you know
tomorrow is March 1st you know and uh
it's just getting closer for you to
leave and whatever and this was
interesting during Jennifer's interview
at the Renwick hotel in New York City
Joe was serious and kept up a brave face
but in what felt like a telling moment
he wiped back tears during a break it
was after a tough topic the lingering
prospect of deportation back to his
native Italy after he serves his time
yeah I mean there's a chance of anything
happened you know I mean there's nothing
that in life that you know is certain
but I mean you know we'll deal with that
when you know when I get out you know
what I deal with a day-by-day well they
also gave us some insight it's their
money situation Teresa told us they have
restructured their finances
she said she's looking for a job and
she'll be back on the Real Housewives
for season seven later this year as long
as they're careful with their taxes
right yeah gotta be tough